[Musique]
vendredi 13 mars ce soir des 4,60
une émission spéciale de deux heures à
situation exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles
fermer toutes les écoles cégeps
universités et services de garde on or
la responsabilité de le faire une autre
en face va être sur comment aider les
canadiens dans ce moment difficile
aujourd'hui le conseil et de reporter ou
d'annuler tout voyage non essentiel
le gouvernement du canada première des
mesures de relance fiscales important on
ne prévoit aucune pénurie de nourriture
en europe
aznar beacon des épi center of de
pandemic avoir deux libye dans cette
période c'est aplanir la courbe il aviv
où les mêmes que je réalise très bien
que je vous en demande beaucoup de
racines coved nineteen masque b team
canada
[Musique]
tous ensemble pour prévenir la corvée de
19 et sa grande propagation dans le fond
pour éviter le pire
bonsoir à vous bien mener cette émission
spéciale les mesurer l'ampleur de la
situation frappe l'imaginaire
on n'a jamais vécu ça en fait la
pandémie de coronavirus impose une
nouvelle réalité du jamais vu on doit
tous adapter c'est une nouvelle vie qui
s'annonce pour nous tous collectivement
enfin mais individuellement dans nos
milieux de travail au cours de cette
émission nos experts répondront à vos
questions encore ce soir sur l'isolément
volontaires notamment le marché du
travail les obligations les droits les
responsabilités les voyages vous nous
avez et non des deux questions sur cette
question là et bien sûr on va revenir
sur les risques pour la santé notamment
julie émond était avec nous encore ce
soir pour recevoir les questions des
téléspectateurs julie vous avez toutes
sortes de questions de réaction de
commentaires face à justement ce sujet
qui fait couler énormément d'encre donc
voici les moyens pour nous contacter
pour nous écrire sur twitter avec le mot
clic rdi 24 60 par courriel à l'adresse
habituelle 24-70 robert radio canada.ca
et aussi nous sommes en diffusion
simultanée sur facebook live vous pouvez
donc également nous écrire au bas de la
diffusion vidéo nous envoyer vos
questions vos commentaires vos réactions
va les porter tout au long de l'émission
et bien sûr les ériger à nos experts qui
sont sur le plateau avec merci julie à
mes côtés je vous présente les invités
docteur cécile tremblay microbiologistes
infectiologues
on sort de tout reprendre lé docteur
pascale brillon un psychologue
spécialisé notamment ceux qui sont
traumatisés parce qu'on sent qu'il ya
beaucoup d'inquiétudes dans la société
en ce moment dr diane francoeur
président de la fédération des médecins
spécialistes du québec bonsoir de thau
francoeur vous allez aborder pour nous
la question la capacité du système de
santé de fonctionner à son meilleur avec
la détermination des gens qui
travaillent dans ce milieu à qui on rend
hommage tous les premiers ministres ont
fait je pense au jour
au cours des derniers jours et andréanne
st-arnaud avec nous parce que andréanne
on va aborder avec vous comme avec les
collègues à québec à ottawa
les nouvelles du jour à québec notre
site de bureaux sébastien bovet bonsoir
c'est ma madeleine de mort est apte à
voir alors j'ai commencé avec vous ces
bassins j'espère vous aviez saluer
madeleine oui mais oui c'est beau c'est
alors la fermeture des garderies de
toutes les écoles du primaire jusqu'à
l'université on s'y attendait un petit
peu mais le dosage depuis début de la
semaine
ces petites doses à petite dose là pour
arriver à avaler tout ça il ya une
gradation au cours de la semaine
rappelez-vous lundi monsieur legault
disait on était un peu inquiet mais il
n'y a pas il faut pas adopter
nécessairement des mesures or on se
retrouve quatre jours plus tard avec la
fermeture complète du réseau scolaire au
québec les services de garde les écoles
primaires les écoles secondaires les
cégeps les universités à partir de lundi
alors qu hier le directeur de la santé
publique
esquiver un peu la question des écoles
en disant on n'en est pas là qu'est ce
qui a changé dans les 24 heures pour que
le gouvernement adopte cette cette
décision en l'air il ya l'ontario qui a
décidé de fermer ses écoles pour trois
semaines il ya de nombreuses écoles qui
ont été fermées aujourd'hui en disant
faut qu'on prenne un pas de recul pour
s'adapter aux nouvelles mesures
annoncées hier par le gouvernement le
goût notamment les interdictions de
rassemblements de 250 personnes dont il
ya un équilibre entre l'aspect santé
publique de dire il faut garder des gens
qui sont peut-être aller en voyage
pendant la semaine de relâche la semaine
dernière et avec leurs parents et qui
pourrait être un vecteur de propagation
de la maladie et l'aspect politique
aussi où on veut rassurer les gens qu'on
prend les mesures qui sont dictées par
la science très bien madeleine tout est
donc à voir aussi de nouvelles consignes
des restrictions notamment quant à la
provenance de l'étranger de certains de
certains appareils
et là aussi on veut essayer de trouver
un équilibre parce qu'il y avait de la
pression pour essayer de contrôler
davantage les entrées aux frontières ce
que le gouvernement fédéral décide de
faire c'est de limiter le nombre
d'aéroports ou des avions internationaux
pourront se poser pour consent
entrez les efforts de surveillance avec
des agents de contrôle qui pourront
poser des questions aux voyageurs
on en a aussi à tous les voyageurs de
l'étranger de se placer en quarantaine
volontaire mais aux voyageurs qui
viennent d'iran d'italie et de la région
dubaï en chine de se placer en
quarantaine obligatoire pour une période
de 14 jours et aussi des mesures qui
sont annoncées pour les bateaux de
croisière donc ceux qui contiennent plus
de 500 passagers ne pourront pas
accoster sur les côtes canadiennes d'ici
le 1er juillet prochain
donc ça ce sont des mesures qui sont
déjà en place mais on réfléchit à la
possibilité d'ajouter certains contrôles
par exemple de limiter certains avions
certains vols en fonction de leur pays
d'origine cette décision n'est pas prise
mais vraiment le gouvernement semble se
garder la porte ouverte à avoir des
mesures de contrôle encore plus ou moins
volandri en dessous de mots font tout ce
que le pas encore répondu au canada de
manière claire et nette au geste de
donald trump lui carrément de fermer ses
frontières à l'europe définit
aujourd'hui par le web est ce comme
l'épicentre maintenant de cette pandémie
alors je vais tout de suite chez andré
alpa profonde analyse à 3 andré en est
quand même eu des mesures économiques
annoncées tant à québec qu'à ottawa
oui mais en fait ça fait plusieurs jours
maintenant que les milieux économiques
réclament des mesures pour essayer de
freiner l'impact de cette propagation du
virus et on a eu un ut troyes important
du côté de t'avoir entre autres
aujourd'hui conférence de presse
conjointe entre le ministre fédéral des
finances et le gouverneur de la banque
du canada stephen poloz en ce qui
concerne la banque du canada on a
annoncé une autre baisse du taux
directeur une deuxième en moins de deux
semaines
encore une fois une baisse d'un demi
point pourcentage le taux directeur qui
passe à 0,75 pour cent au canada
ça veut dire que les coûts d'emprunt
pour les particuliers les taux
hypothécaires différents près tout ça va
baisser on veut donner aux canadiens et
aux entreprises aussi plus de facilité à
avoir un coussin financier c'est
l'objectif donc est d'ailleurs la banque
du canada n'a pas exclu l'idée de
baisser encore les taux ou d'injecter
des liquidités sur les marchés
ça c'est pour la banque du canada
général de son côté est toujours en
train de préparer je vous le rappelle
son grand plan daide avec des mesures
fiscales qui viendront vraisemblablement
la semaine prochaine mais on a quand
même annoncé deux mesures aujourd'hui
d'une part on va consentir 10 milliards
de dollars en prêts à des entreprises
surtout des pme
ce sera géré par l' exportation et
développement canada et la banque de
développement du canada et deuxième
mesure le surintendant des institutions
financières a annoncé que les banques
en fait on va à baisser le ratio de
stabilité financière ça veut dire qu'ils
auront à conserver dans leurs coffres
moins d'argent
ça libère 300 milliards de dollars en
liquide des concours or là aussi
consentir en prêt alors on veut avec
cette première étape faire souffler un
peu le planète économique là si vous
voulez okada répondait en parlais tout à
l'heure en traînant avec justement
dorment à dorval du conseil du patronat
mais je vous regarde le cbc un plus bas
de laine vous êtes un peu vous incarnez
les porte parole des deux capitales
alors que les deux premiers ministres ne
soit pas nécessairement sur la même
longueur d'onde quant à la sécurité des
citoyens notamment les gardes-frontières
sébastien mais pour le moment il n'y a
pas d'animosité
du côté de québec on se contente de
vouloir rassurer les citoyens les
entreprises les travailleurs que ce qui
se passe quoi je vous dirais qu'il ya
une petite déception une déception qui a
été exprimée en coulisses après le point
presse de justin trudeau ont trouvé que
ça manquait un peu de fermeté vis-à-vis
des tra des voyageurs étrangers
une déception transmis semble-t-il par
monsieur legault lors d'un appel
conférence avec tous les premiers
ministres du pays dont monsieur trudeau
on aurait probablement souhaité des
mesures plus fermes à l'égard des
voyageurs étrangers on est dénoncée
l'espèce d'incohérence des dernières
heures ou des québécois qui revenait au
pays se dire d'aller en isolement
pendant 14 jours mais que des voyageurs
étrangers pouvaient se promener
librement
je comprends qu'on a resserré un peu
haché à ottawa mais pour certains pays
uniquement
est ce que monsieur legault aurait voulu
que d'autres pays soient visés par ce
resserrement de dd pour le poli et
voyageurs étrangers
c'est peut-être le cas on est un peu
choqué de savoir par exemple qu'il y
avait encore des avions de chine qui
atterrissait à montréal cela étant dit
le gouvernement oui veut rassurer et
prendre des mesures extrêmes pour dire
nous sommes en contrôle de la situation
on applique le dicton vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir et on sait que ça va
chambouler votre vie mais on essaie de
faire en sorte que ces lâches en boule
le moins possible il va y avoir des
services de garde pour les travailleurs
de première ligne
les infirmières les ambulanciers les
médecins par exemple pour contrer
l'effet où l'impact de la fermeture des
écoles
on va s'assurer que pour les gens qui
doivent rester à la maison qui sont des
travailleurs autonomes par exemple il y
ait des compensations on demande aux
employeurs d'être compréhensifs aussi
donc on essaie d'enrobé ces mesures qui
bouscule pas mal nos comportements et à
préciser pour l'instant ces quatorze
jours de fermeture aussi durée indéfinie
la médecine 14 jours dans une jarre est
évalué à les évaluer
parce qu'on nous a dit y est ça ne
faisait que commencer capitalise sur
plusieurs semaines
madeleine tout à l'heure le président
entrant dans son point de presse a
reconnu avoir parlé au premier ministre
trudeau d'ailleurs c'est la conversion
paraît-il eu lieu pendant les
transitions bière mais disent que je
peux parler des frontières du tout c'est
étonnant non oui en tout cas il ya eu
tout un effort je vous dirais de
lobbying au lendemain de l'annoncé du
président entre hommes qu'il allait
empêcher les voyageurs européens de
rentrer aux états unis ou de visiter les
états unis parce qu'on ne voulait
surtout pas du côté canadien qu'on ferme
la frontière terrestre entre le canada
et les états unis
le du côté canadien on a insisté sur
l'importance de cette frontière là il ya
quatre cent mille personnes par jour qui
la traverse est frontières et l'été
essentielle à la santé économique du
pays
donc on voulait bien assuré que cette
frontière là pourrait demeurer ouverte
surtout qu'on n'avait pas été prévenu du
côté canadien que le président entre
hommes s'apprêtaient à empêcher les
voyageurs européens de venir aux états
unis donc on ne fait du démarchage de ce
côté là mais on n'a pas senti du côté
canadien par la suite qu'il y avait de
la pression de la part de
l'administration américaine pour qu'il y
ait fermeture des frontières ou qu'on
imite nécessairement ce que faisait
l'administration
je continue quand même avec vous
madeleine amendes pour ceux avec
sébastien et en
quand même c'est quand même une nouvelle
importante notre premier ministre en
isolement volontaire parce que son
épouse est atteint de la corvée de dix
neuf de retour d'un voyage je crois au
royaume-uni où il ya quand même beaucoup
de cols à bord et que c'était une
exception aux yeux de donald trump ce
pays grèce quand même étonnant à lille a
fait le point sur son état de santé sur
sa nouvelle vie en quarantaine mais
est-ce qu'ils aient le goût renard est
capable de faire face à la crise bien
c'est un peu pour ça qu'il ya eu ce
point de presse devant sa résidence
officielle aujourd'hui pour démontrer je
suis en forme que je suis capable de
travailler
c'est ce qu'ils voulaient démontrer
d'une façon d'essayer de rassurer les
canadiens en disant qu'ils ne présentent
aucun symptôme
donc il a expliqué que selon les avis
qu'il a reçu de ses médecins des experts
de la santé publique c'est pas
nécessaire de subir un test de lakovic
19 parce que ce test là serait non
concluants c'est un test qui a été
conçue lorsqu'il y a des symptômes et
justin trudeau dit qu'il n'en a pas
donc qu'ils peuvent continuer de faire
son travail sans être testés il dit que
si jamais où c'est ce qu'on comprend si
jamais ils présentent des symptômes il
subirait le test mais pour le moment et
il déclare qu'il n'est pas atteint et
qu'il peut continuer de faire des appels
il a parlé aux enfants vous l'avez dit
il a parlé au premier ministre
britannique au premier ministre italien
à emmanuel macron aussi de la france
aujourd'hui donc il continue à faire son
travail le parlent aux premiers
ministres provinciaux ont aussi mais
c'est quand même un inconvénient on
s'entend il et il peut pas avoir de
contacts dans en personne avec les
autres membres du gouvernement qui avoir
un geste d'urgence donc par
vidéoconférence autrement là mais on a
su que les enfants mais je voulais gros
ce matin c'est pas la seule mesure
exception du côté d'ottawa il ya eu
cette suspension des travaux à la
chambre des communes jusqu'au 20 avril
ça s'était pas vus en senteurs que la
chambre comme ça à jour de ses travaux
pour des raisons de santé publique alors
très bien mais là vous rester au boulot
vous n'êtes pas encore en télétravail
madeleine ça me fait quand vous voyez
alors pour s' avec andrée anne quand
même y avait des marchés aujourd'hui
toujours et se sont ressaisis un petit
peu parce que bilan de la semaine quand
même ça a été pénible on a eu encore une
semaine en montagnes russes déjà il ya
deux semaines on disait que ça avait été
la pire semaine en bourse depuis la
crise financière de 2008
alors vous pouvez dire ça de la semaine
qui se termine c'est était vraiment
pénible encore une fois mais oui on a eu
un rebond aujourd'hui au fur et à mesure
notamment du discours de dans notre
chambre où on évoquer l'état d'urgence
on évoquait de l'argent qui pourraient
être débloqués pour venir en aide aux
américains aux entreprises
au fur et à mesure de la journée donc sa
remontée on a eu en fait la meilleure
journée en bourse aujourd'hui depuis
2008 avec des gros doigts mais c'est en
contrepartie ça faisait suite à l'une
des pires journées en 30 ans en bourse
alors les montagnes russes les
variations sont extrêmes mais si on fait
le bilan de la semaine ça tout de même
été une semaine douloureuse
effectivement on a des pertes de 8 à 12%
pour les principaux indices en amérique
du nord et tous les signaux la montre
que c'est loin d'être terminé
dieu merci andré hahn en terminant
sébastien point de presse du premier
ministre de docteur arruda demain et
dimanche je crois à 13h suivi sur wii
c'est un exercice quotidien auquel s
astreindre le gouvernement au cours des
prochains jours avec la santé et du côté
d'ottawa madeleine est ce qu'on 115 on
s'attend à voir des prêtresses
idéalement quotidiens en semaine mais on
dit bien idéalement parce que on pense
aussi à la santé à la forme d'aidés
docteur qui sont alors au point de
presse quotidien là on veut s'assurer
que tout le monde tienne le coup pendant
cette finale on voit bien que les médias
jouent un rôle important dans la
transmission de l'espoir et peut-être un
contre et l'inquiétude merci à vous
trois merci on envoie une madame y à
partir de la semaine prochaine il ya des
médecins au québec que ce soit dans les
hôpitaux dans les cliniques médicales
qui vont pouvoir donner des services par
téléconsultation je vous dire également
que en lien avec le dépistage on déploie
au québec 12 une douzaine de cliniques
de plus
cela met la santé aujourd'hui je reçois
maintenant sur le plateau de diane
francoeur président de la fédération des
médecins spécialistes du québec bonsoir
docteur francoeur sur quoi madame mais
cannes faisait allusion notamment à
séville est davantage de croire les
omnipraticiens qui pourrait faire de la
télé médecine on sait tous où rôdent si
vous osiez des styles produit c'est
d'après maroc et ce cas oui comment vous
avez fait ça dépasse et non pas avec des
bolides ont le tester au bureau on a
testé la plateforme on a envoyé nos
employés on lui fait prendre des photos
pour voir si on pouvait voir les lésions
internes et non non c'est vraiment une
excellente nouvelle ça faisait plusieurs
semaines qu'on demande au ministère de
nous trouver une plate forme parce que
vous savez à chaque jour on change de
direction je dirais par précaution on a
pris des mesures importantes au début de
la semaine et c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire
j'en profite pour féliciter monsieur
legault il a été courageux
on est fiers de notre premier ministre
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire maintenant
bon plusieurs cliniques ont annulé des
rendez-vous électif qu'on appelle les
circuits chirurgie pour la semaine
prochaine parce qu'on n'était pas encore
certain d'avoir accès à la plateforme
aussitôt qu'elle va être déployée
fonctionnel on va essayer de voir tous
les patients qui sont à risque ça veut
dire nos grands malades
les patients qui ont de la
chimiothérapie et de la radiothérapie
les immuno supprimer les maladies
chroniques on ne veut tellement pas
amené à l'hôpital pour qu'ils soient
contaminés alors le produit textant
fonctionner mais c'est ce qui est
intéressant là dedans c'est que pour nom
ne vous est pas assez parlé depuis un
mois qu'on parle de du coronavirus on
parle de la prévention des précautions
des craintes qu'ont doc que senghor
jestin de santé pour n'oublie peut-être
les patients qui font en sorte que le
système est déjà à plein fouet la récré
des gens à risque et que c'est à savoir
est-ce qu'on guérit on soit untel ou
unetelle qu'on soit obligé de faire des
choix extrêmement déchirant qui mettrait
en danger la vie des autres patients
alors c'est pour ça qu'on s'est entendu
avec l'équipe de madame mais kahn savait
on passe beaucoup beaucoup d'heures à
partir de très tôt le matin jusqu'à très
tard le soir pour essayer trouver
problème solution problème solution une
collaboration exemplaire alors on
s'entend qui est certaines personnes
âgées
où certaines personnes qui sont pas
conforté avec les ordinateurs airs
toujours le bon vieux téléphone qui
reste un outil de communication les
médecins auront la permission de soigner
les patients à distance ou temporaire
ces deux autres temporaires pour le
moment où pour parce qu'en france jour
le jour en raison mais ce que c'est
parce qu'on a toujours des réserves
effet l'école médecin est ce qu il
fallait que tout enfin qu'ils voient de
près et tout l souhaitez vous que ce
soit une mesure pérenne qui durent
longtemps avec eux c'est sûr qu'on va on
va les stores et davantage le meilleur
plus encadrées par la suite mais en tout
premier lieu il faut décider quelle est
la valeur ajoutée pour le passé à ce
qu'on prend le risque de les amener de
l'eau contaminée ou peut-être de se
priver de certains outils qui sont non
essentiels mais vous savez en
télémédecine ont fait des miracles alors
maintenant qu'on est la plateforme
nouveau pouvoir ajouter des juges ou de
dents qui nous permettent même d'écouter
le locker par exemple et aurait engagé
les urgences
oui ben en fait éventuellement dans
l'événement de cette crise là je pense
qu'on va changer nos façons de faire et
nous en sortirons tous grands vie mais
l'a pour l'instant c'est arrivé
aujourd'hui s'est définitivement la
bonne nouvelle de la journée est la même
qu accepte un petit cochon n'aurait les
patients qui ont chistiane pour la crise
était un enjeu mais moi mon rôle c'est
de m'assurer qu'on soit capable de
donner des services et on est allé
chercher tous les points 1-1 après
l'autre pour pouvoir y arriver et les
échos parce que cette fois la porte
parole de toussaint desanti ce n'est pas
là pour la surprise ce soir parce qu'on
passe aux infirmières à tous les
techniciens techniciens qui travaillent
deux autos tous les spécialistes de
toutes sortes de disciplines les auteurs
afin thérapeute et autres
est ce que le climat qui règne à ce que
sont les échos que vous avez quant à
l'inquiétude ou et il va falloir que
vous aimeriez visiter demain parce que
je travaille à 8 heures cette nuit alors
je passe la nuit à l'hôpital pour dire
oui mais les échos c'est sûr que comme
tout le monde je pense que le personnel
était inquiet mais il faut vraiment
rassuré les gens pour l'instant c'est
pas facile la crise elle est là il faut
prendre des décisions rapides et les met
en marche mais pour l'instant on n'a pas
de patients qui sont empirées long faut
le dire on est capable de de s'occuper
des gens qui sont très malades
on se sait qu'il ya un problème avec le
8 1 qui a été transférée avec un nouveau
numéro moi j'ai offert l'aide de tous
les médecins qui sont en isolement ou en
quarantaine de collaborer aux huit
heures on est capable de répondre au
téléphone est capable de rassurer les
patients et on sait qu'on a une de mes
membres docteur couach qui est un
microbiologiste ray très présente dans
toute cette crise qui a appliqué et qui
fait du téléphone et c'est une
excellente je m'adapte aux reproches et
une amie de l'émission comme les autres
invités on va lui parlais tout à l'heure
elle est en isolement volontaire l'on va
lui parlais tout à l'heure pour qu'elle
nous explique bien les consignes les
contraintes et commence à lui pense
inspirante du couple trudeau aussi parce
que madame sophie grégoire drdo
elle-même est atteindre la coville 19
alors diane francoeur merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur le plateau ce soir merci
infiniment
et puis je dois dire que le docteur
alain poirier qui directeur de la santé
publique notamment pour la région de
l'estrie s'est joint à nous à notre
panel
alors je prends avoir des réactions de
de vous doter reprendre les pensées mais
rendrions de ce qu'on entend depuis sur
les mesures qui ont été annoncées
aujourd'hui je pense que les mesures
étaient nécessaires je pense qu'on voit
dans la bonne direction surtout dans la
nasse et on n'en fait pas je pense qu'on
en fait assez mais toujours approprié
par rapport à la situation actuelle
c'est sûr que si on voit que la
transmission se met à se faire dans la
communauté il va falloir aussi encore
west les mesures que l'on qu'on l'a on
doit devoir prendre mais c'est bien d'y
aller avec une mesure à la fois ça vous
permet à la société de s'adapter ça
permet au système de santé de s'adapter
aussi vous avez pas idée de combien de
mes mots nous avons reçu à l'hôpital
toute la journée qu'ils nous envoient
des directives auquel tout le monde doit
s'adapter
alors je pense qu'on fait une bonne job
à le faire mais c'est quand même c'est
lourd à l'embryon vous un prix ce soit
pour réfléchir avec nous sur la manière
de calmer les inquiétudes les envois
qu'est ce qui vous frappe le plus ça
passe quand on demande à ce que l'on
observé une certaine panique à pied dans
deux mois plus tôt entre lundi et
vendredi dans au président et de
l'organisation et des politiques qui a
été fait
donc effectivement je pense que la
question se pose comment est-ce qu'on
peut maximiser la rive résilience
sociale
des québécois pour traverser cette
épreuve le mieux passé est-ce que je
peux parler de tout repos risque est en
ligne
à sherbrooke je suis là weir est à
parier bienvenus à noter mission vous
sortez toujours derrière d'un point de
presse je crois régionale et une
émission spéciale de radio canada dans
la région dont vous avez manqué le début
on a beaucoup d'écrits les mesures
annoncées par québec est ce que québec
est allé aussi loin que québec pouvait
aller dans les circonstances avec ses
annonces de fermeture de garderie
jusqu'à l'université ça s'imposait il ya
des considérations très particulière on
a cette opportunité de voir ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs avant ici est ce qu'on
veut éviter parce que c'est des pays qui
ont des capacités et puis qui ont des
systèmes de santé publique organisée et
c'est l'éclosion en europe notamment en
italie que les experts observer qu'ils
sont dit on veut pas ça donc on prend
des mesures qui ont l'air un peu forte
d'un donne par exemple la transmission
encore ici ça viendra sûrement mais
c'est tout dit quand importés mais puis
comme il ya eu la semaine de relâche à
la sauce et les mesures en milieu
scolaire les avions donc il ya eu une
escalade des mesures alors que les gens
voient pas encore tellement la maladie
sinon on la voit beaucoup dans les
médias et dans d'autres pays
mais c'est ça qu'on veut éviter pour
embourbé nous nos simples on a perdu on
a perdu sur terre pour y aura sûrement
la communication va sans doute se réfère
jeu de la question que je posais au
docteur poirier relation parce qu'on est
elle aussi loin qu'on pouvait aller où
on doit encore notamment sa fameuse que
sur les frontières mais soit question
des frontières c'est certaine que des
choses à améliorer encore la discordance
entre les les canadiens qui reviennent
et les voyageurs étrangers ne fait aucun
sens si logique alors il faut régler ça
absolument
et puis la question de l'information qui
est donnée à l'air on part aux gens qui
reviennent de voyage c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut régler que pas de raison de
parler sourire qu'on retrouve cloud oui
ça alors julie et m'ont entendu sorte de
terme dans les mesures qui sont
annoncées d'importants distinguer la
notion de de quarantaine d'isolement de
d'éloignement ou de distanciation
sociale parce que les gens rentrent à la
maison là depuis
depuis aujourd'hui la pose cette
question anne marie finances à dire a
exposé plusieurs questions en fait mais
avec tous ces termes qu'on utilise à
toutes les sauces permettez moi
l'expression
j'ai posé la question un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui au docteur karl weiss
microbiologiste bien sûr qu'ils étaient
sur notre plateau hier à savoir comment
on peut bien distinguer ces termes est
ce qu'ils impliquent ce qu'ils
signifient donc je vais vous distinguer
entre autres 40 l isolement très très
important et ensuite on va parler des
mesures de distanciation social dans la
quarantaine évidemment ça fait référence
à l'époque alors ce qu'on mettait soit
des marins de retour de voyage en
période de quarantaine donc un isolement
d'un cac 40 jours de sont aujourd'hui
bien sûr c'est différent quand on parle
d'une quarantaine
selon dr weiss on n'est plus dans
l'ordre la sémantique donc un terme plus
conceptuelle dans lequel on sous-entend
qu'il ya un groupe de personnes qui sont
mis donc à l'écart que ce soit dans une
région un district un local d'une
localité
ça peut être aussi bien sûr pour
vraiment ce qui concerne une école ou
encore un groupe de voyageurs par
exemple dans un bateau croisière
c'est ce qu'on a remarqué ces dernières
semaines en italie quand on parlait du
nord du pays puis ensuite de l'ensemble
la boîte ans qui était mise en
quarantaine
maintenant si on fait référence au terme
isolement et là c'est très très
important de spécifier ce qu'implique ce
terme beaucoup de choses c'est ce que
préconise d'ailleurs l'organisation
mondiale de la santé oms qu'anne-marie
en termes d'isolement l'organisation
mondiale de la santé recommande que les
personnes en isolement soit dans des
chambres individuelles avec des portes
closes également que les contacts soit
restreint voire interdite du moins
limiter au plus possible tout comme les
déplacements et dans les cas les plus
importants les plus sévères disons on
parle que les visites devrait se faire
avec le port d'équipements de protection
par exemple des gants ou encore des
masses qui a d'ailleurs une adolescente
qui part de ce type d'isolement en
ontario dont deux tournants des images
en fait il ya beaucoup d'autres
personnes qui sont en isolement mais on
avait des images à vous montrer la fait
un voyage à son retour elle présentait
des symptômes et donc elle a été mise en
isolement dans sa résidence en ontario
alors des contacts restreints avec les
membres de la famille comme vous le
voyez on lui apporte l'épicerie les
denrées nécessaires les médicaments et
tout le reste
mais sinon il reste à l'intérieur et
maintenant le troisième terme la
distanciation social ça fait référence à
toutes les mesures d'hygiène
le télétravail par exemple tout ce qu'on
peut faire pour garder une meilleure
distance avec les autres individus qu'on
côtoie la schéma simple à comprendre
on s'éloigne un bras distance ou deux
certains disent si pied d'autres normes
peuvent indiquer entre 1 et 2 mètres
bref on comprend qu'il ya une distance à
respecter regardé quelques vidéos que
j'ai trouvé pour vous ce star sommes
aujourd'hui téléspectateurs labaki a
décidé d'y aller avec une notion du mot
un petit peu il s'est fait donc que
cette cette forme pour se rendre au
marché public ou encore du côté du
pentagone un peu plus tôt cette semaine
le voyez la distance qui illustre ce
journaliste et même chose pour ceux qui
prenaient la parole qui se sont éloignés
tout ça pour vous dire que ce sont des
mesures des comportements dits barrières
qu'on utilise vraiment pour aplanir
cette fameuse courbe c'est à dire pour
que le nombre de cas soit sur une plus
grande échelle de temps et surtout que
ce nombre soit moins élevé afin de ne
pas dépasser le seuil critique de ce que
le réseau de la santé a comme capacité
maximale
très bien merci julie plec pas la pause
on va parler au docteur quoi justement
que vous expliquer concrètement qu'est
ce que ça veut dire et un isolement
et comme le nombre de cas continue de
grimper au canada on va faire le point
avec nos journalistes sur le terrain on
va tous rester avec nous
[Musique]
au fond
alors c'est le monsieur trudeau qui
expliquait sa situation toute nouvelle
devrait vivre à la maison mais commence
à douter se passait à l'intérieur de la
maison
je joins car l'une couach vous êtes
enfin ce témoin c'en scarlett pense
qu'être vous êtes
microbiologiste-infectiologue vous êtes
venus souvent sur notre plateau ce soir
une fois y est
si vous même qui aviez lancé d'ailleurs
l'idée d'aider certaines consignes pour
le milieu de la santé quant aux voyages
et l isolement
vous êtes en isolement volontaire depuis
1 4h à l'atteinte d'un résultat
quel est votre seule chance que votre
situation si on la compare à monsieur
tout ça peut peut-être se ressemblent et
des conjoints des enfants comment
comment ça doit se passer
en fait la différence c'est que chez
nous contrairement à chez monsieur
trudeau vont mari n'est pas positif
encore donc il ya eu des symptômes on
est de retour de voyage
il a été testé et on attend les
résultats donc pas tout à fait dans la
même encore dans le même ordre encore
maintenant comment on fait on sait on
s'est séparé de corps la chambre moi
j'ai eu
j'ai pris le lit à deux étages du fiston
que le fiston avait abandonné parce
qu'il a grandi on te fait garder encore
les lie à deux étages il est la salle de
la salle de bains de la chambre des
maîtres je les laissais à mon mari et
moi j'ai pris la salle de bain avec les
enfants on est quand même chanceux parce
qu'on on a une maison qui est assez
grande pour nous r m
voir des salles de bains dédie donc dans
la journée ben nous on a travaillé toute
la journée c'est pas parce qu'on
travaille complètement bon j'ai été en
lien avec l'hôpital toute la journée
avec différents médias alors analyser
votre mari lui est pas s'approcher de
personnes il faut qu'ils restent
enfermés dans la chambre au non-lieu a
mis un masque est long il ya mis un
masque qui se lave les mains
et donc il est toujours à distance et
pacolli sur les enfants mais il garde
une certaine distance avec les enfants
mais tous potro donc ça va encore
et si on va du côté de t'avoir ou madame
grès world où elle porte la coved 19 on
peut imaginer qu une grande maison est
là elle doit rester nécessairement dans
une seule pièce avoir utilisé une seule
salle de bains pas approcher personnes
qu en est-il pour idéalement une salle
de bains dédié des quartiers qui sont
plus qui lui sont plus réservés mais je
sais pas si elle est là des masques ou
pas c'est sûr que la transmission à
secouer et donc la transmission se fait
comme on l'a toujours dit le père
surtout par gouttelettes et contacte
donc si on ne s'y nos sécrétions
respiratoires le sort papillon et
clément et qu'on se lave les mains à
chaque fois qu on se mouche déjà ça
c'est très bien on est quand même
capable quand on est à la maison de
faire plus attention pub on peut décider
dans un coin de la maison de de faire
moins attention puis de continuer notre
environnement il va falloir qu'on
nettoie cet environnement là une fois
qu'on peut voir à table avec vous là bas
on s'assoit mais si on s'assoit en étant
zigzag c'est à dire que devant moi il
est pas devant moi
ils vont être en diagonale du fait que
si tous ça ira pas vers moi
mais hier soir lui a mangé dans la
cuisine revient à une autre question
parce que madame trop de grégoire lll et
atteindre de la coved 19
on ne sait pas quand envoyé guéri un oui
à peine guéri on remet tout doucement
grand isolement pour 14 jours mais a peu
de geri elle juste dans trois semaines
terrain c'est possible parce que lui
c'est certain god dans 14 jours il va
sortir même si l'époque guéri et comment
on définit la guérison
en fait il ya un article qui a été
publié aujourd'hui ou hier la s'est
récemment où on voit que la
le virus contenait qs être excrété quand
même assez longtemps parfois jusqu'à 21
jours après le début après le début des
symptômes souvent quatre à cinq jours
après la fin des symptômes
donc j'imagine que en théorie on
considère quelqu'un guéri présentement
quand on a deux pcr donc deux tests de
recherche de virus négatif à 24 heures
d'intervalle
donc j'imagine que madame les couacs
prudhom va passer ces tests la laissait
quand ils testent la seront négatives
qu'elle sera déclarée comme
officiellement guéri et en théorie le 14
jours de monsieur trudeau commencerait à
la fin de la période de contagiosité de
madame à moins qu'il ait réussi à aller
complètement verte à ses seuls parce que
le 14 jours c'est à partir du dernier
moment où tu pourrais être infecté
autrement parce qu'ils pourraient disons
que le pire scénario
ça serait qui le contractent j'ai pas à
la dernière journée où elle est excrété
virus mais lui serait à ce moment-là
l'incubation entre 2 et 12 2 et 12 jours
après ce contact là donc en théorie
c'est la théorie
ça serait ça laisse à désirer dos des
semaines ça ça peut être des semaines
effectivement mais en même temps plus
ouais on est symptomatique moyon l'ex
crête donc pour l'instant je pense pas
qu'on ait encore
enfin moi je les connais pas les mesures
de santé publique pour déclarer pour
pour décréter la durée d'isolement du
conjoint de quelqu'un qui serait malade
jésus pas vu encore parce que la
question des enfants maintenant qu'elle
est la règle pour les enfants vous même
vous avez des enfants ce temps ce serait
formidable si ni votre marine et vous
n'étiez porteurs de huatai de la coved
mais si vous devenez tous les deux les
quelqu'un il faut s'occuper des enfants
donc avec des masques et j'imagine avec
la protection par les enfants eux aussi
doivent à leur tour être en quarantaine
pour plus longtemps
oui mais pas pensons gros quand même ils
sont capables de gérer tout seul alors
on pleure il pourrait même nous faire à
manger
profitez-en écoutez on va vous souhaitez
quand même une bonne encore une 41ème en
isolement ça peut durer 48 heures si
vous appreniez que vous étiez négative
tous les deux on vous rappelle réseau wi
fi parce que j'ai pas de symptômes ça
sert à rien de cet art ici on n'a pas de
symptômes
donc j'en ai pas c'est juste mon mari
qui était lui alors tant mieux s'il est
négatif docteur couach merci beaucoup
nous avons parlé ce soir nous avoir
expliqué un peu plus les contraintes les
consignes les règles à suivre pour vivre
cet isolement que plusieurs québécois
canadiens vont devoir vivre dans les
prochains jours et prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup merci à vous des foules
par d'attraper le respect chez nous là
si tout le monde est en train de chier
comme ça moi je moi mais j'ai aussi su
attaquer on ne prévoit aucune pénurie de
nourriture
donc c'est important que les gens
s'inquiètent paul les épiceries vont
continuer d'être approvisionné il a
désormais deux cents probable cas
confirmés ou probables ou confirmés le
corona virus au canada on l'a vu ottawa
danse à son sort à son tour des mesures
draconiennes pour contrer la propagation
mais les provinces font aussi leur parle
vous voyez les chiffres on va faire un
survol de la situation et d'est en ouest
avec
votre vie de paul à moncton bonsoir
davide gentile à montréal sébastien st
françois à toronto bonsoir et qui me
permette à vancouver on apprend par
ailleurs aller sans que vieira
interrompt son service entre montréal et
halifax et toronto et vancouver jusqu'au
27 mars justement pour freiner la
propagation alors je vais commencer avec
vous louise bénévoles aux nouveaux
produits qu'on vient d'annoncer
certaines fermetures est vraiment après
plus de deux heures de rencontre le
premier ministre du nouveau brunswick
qui a finalement indiqué que les écoles
publiques de la province vont être
fermés et ce dès lundi pour une période
de deux semaines les situations qu'on va
donc réévaluer et anne-marie pour ce qui
est des garderies a aucune indication à
ce sujet donc elle reste ouverte
c'est sans trop de surprise je vous
dirais parce que déjà plus tôt
aujourd'hui la médecin hygiéniste en
chef du nouveau-brunswick avait
mentionné que si le gouvernement allait
en ce sens c'est à dire de fermer ses
écoles publiques qu'elle allait appuyer
cette décision alors je vous invite à
écouter monsieur bling fixe qui est a
accordé un point de presse quelques
minutes de cela l'atlantic etc encore
épargnée par la pandémie mais les
provinces ont déjà annoncé le des
mesures pour prévenir la propagation
disons un peu épargné par ce qu'on a
déjà un cas qui est recensé ça se trouve
au nouveau brunswick dans le sud est de
la province donc oui les autres
provinces et même le nouveau brunswick
qui se prépare qui anticipent d'avoir
plusieurs autres cas d'ici les
prochaines semaines même prochains jours
mais oui on parle de mesures qui sont
mises en place on parle par exemple de
cette recommandation d'annuler ou
d'éviter tout événement de plus de 150
personnes deux des restrictions par
rapport aux visites dans les foyers de
soins dont voilà l'état de la situation
et j'ai terminé en vous disant qu'il ya
le premier ministre de
l'île-du-prince-édouard qui est
présentement en isolement
d'abord là dessus merci beaucoup et lui
l'épaule au revoir
à voir et david gentili québec promet de
régler le cafouillage la ligne
téléphonique et elle vous sentez écouter
quand j'ai dit au docteur arruda hier
sur le plateau que celle ligne marchait
pas le 1 8 7 7
je pense qu'ils étaient de l'aisne et
dans l'âme et canada pourrait fâcher
aujourd'hui elle était très fâché parce
qu'effectivement ça fonctionnait très
mal hier notre collègue olivier bachand
a attendu deux heures avant de
finalement parler à quelqu'un mais
c'était non pas une infirmière même
travailleuse sociale donc oui on
n'exagère pas en disant qu'il y a eu des
ratés aujourd'hui madame et cannes a dit
oubliez lui tant pour les coronavirus
c'est le fameux 1 8 7 7 6 4 4 4 5 4 5
donné le canot a dit qu'elle allait
s'occuper personnellement de régler ce
problème là on les côtes
mais ce que je veux dire aussi à la
population c'est qu'il manquait du
personnel à l'info santé mais là je peux
dire aux gens qu'on va avoir 80 8
infirmières de plus dès maintenant au
service d'info santé pour répondre alors
c'est un engagement que je prends
il va être réglé ce problème là
aujourd'hui même je vais suivre ça
personnellement
est-ce que vous avez essayé dernièrement
david le numéro on nous dit que ça
fonctionne alors où on se parle à 19h40
le plateau parce que ça marche que
keller ce niveau jusqu'à 20 heures
je ne peux pas vous le dire sans papiers
je me verrais été posée le quatrième
texte des pros 24 heures alors peut-être
qu'ils devront emmener en prolongation
des heures également
cela dit les cliniques de dépistage on
sait que l'athlé le dépistage va ça va
augmenter au québec mais de manière
considérable on nous dit que ça va
passer de 3 à 15 cliniques
à partir de quand on ne le sait pas trop
une chose est certaine
parce qu'on augmente le nombre de
cliniques faut aussi augmenter la
capacité d'analysé des tests et ça ça va
être multiplié par 16 donc oui on veut
tenter de se donner les outils pour
attaquer de front le coc vite de 19 et
madame mais cannes a même dit que s'il
le fallait on allait retarder des
opérations pour s'assurer de mettre des
ressources à cet endroit là on
commençait télévisée ceci dit oui entre
autres dans le sus de l'est de l'île de
montréal où on interdira les visites
dans les ch celle des et les hôpitaux
pour protéger les personnes âgées on
écoute là dessus le directeur général du
sus de l'est de l'île de montréal
tout ce qu'ils sont en train de vie des
raisons de naissance cd et d'autres
permission spéciale quand j'irai à la
pièce mais le message de valse et en
limitent l'accès à nos milieux
hospitaliers série
donc voilà de marée humaine qui a
commencé dans une toute autre ambiance
mais mercredi jeudi on a senti que
l'inquiétude pour ne pas dire certaine
panique s'est installée dans le réseau
de la santé
merci beaucoup d'avis nova commenté
anisé soit cela avec pascale brillon
sébastien à toronto
la ville vient aussi d'annoncer de
nouvelles mesures oui exactement parce
que en ontario aujourd'hui on est à 81
quand un client sur 120 cas ajouté en
ontario donc une autre journée
excessivement occupée pour la plus
grosse pour vin chaud payer beaucoup de
mesures annoncées au nouveau au
provincial
entre autres pas de rassemblement de
plus de 250 personnes ça avait déjà été
fait dans quelques autres provinces
mais là c'est une recommandation
officielle de la santé publique de
l'ontario pendant que vous voyez des
images du centre de commande des mesures
d'urgence de la ville de toronto qu'on a
pu visiter aujourd'hui que nos collègues
ont pu visiter donc pas de rassemblement
de plus de 250 personnes les
rassemblements plus petits on suggère
aux gens qui veulent en faire des
organisateurs de surveiller ce que ça
peut donner avec leur santé publique
régionale on a le maire john tory qui en
isolement volontaire lui aussi revenu
d'une mission économique en angleterre
doit se soumettre aux demandes aux
directives du fédéral et aussi de sa
propre médecin hygiéniste en chef qui a
recommandé aujourd'hui que tous les gens
sur le territoire de toronto qui
revenait de l'extérieur du pays incluant
des états unis devraient se mettre en
quarantaine pendant 14 jours il ya
certaines parties du transport en commun
qui ont dont on va ralentir la fréquence
entre autres les trains de banlieue en
fin de semaine la liaison personnes que
je centre-ville ont fermé bibliothèque
les piscines municipales laissant un
commentaire
on suspend le conseil municipal jusqu'au
5 avril bref beaucoup de mesures comme
ça à toronto en ontario aujourd'hui et
des emplois du secteur de la santé
aimerait que le gouvernement quand même
en fasse davantage
oui je peux vous dire à marie que
je discute avec des gens de ce cas la
santé depuis presque six semaines
maintenant et il y à des mesures qu'on
me susurrer à l'oreille qu'on aurait
voulu voir mettre en place beaucoup plus
tôt qui commencent à être mises en place
en ce moment donc il ya bien des gens
incluant les syndiqués du secteur de la
santé que vous voyez qui ont une dent ce
moment un peu contre le gouvernement le
gouvernement de fraude
je vous laisse écouter un des grands
patrons des plus grands syndicats du
secteur de la santé en ontario shdm en
quittant le site de bonheur ils ont donc
été reconnu pour son franc-parler en
ontario qui dit on leur dit aux
fonctionnaires avec qui on discute si
vous pensez que c'est sécuritaire si
vous pensez que l'on devrait faire le
travail dans certaines des conditions
auxquelles on fait face
allez-y vous aller nettoyer et devinez
quoi ben ils n'y vont pas nettoyé
soucier de président deux des plus
grandes centrales syndicales en ontario
sa venue ça vous donne une idée du ton
qui prévaut en ontario je termine en
vous disant il ya aussi des délais pour
la ligne info santé de l'ontario de 4 à
5 heures à ce moment en ontario de ce
qu'on peut voir corriger la situation
oui on nous dit qu'il ya des infirmières
qui vont être rappelés mais disons qu'à
4 5 en ce moment je tenais amélioration
par rapport à ce qu'il y avait eu au
cours des derniers jours
eh bien merci beaucoup c'est bastien qui
maintenant on vient d'annoncer 11
nouveaux cas en colombie britannique
on parle donc anne marie de 64,4
coronavirus depuis le tout début de
cette épidémie si en
colombie-britannique la bonne nouvelle
selon les autorités c'est qu'il ya six
personnes qui sont maintenant rétablis
de ce virus entre temps un peu comme
c'est le cas partout pays à plusieurs
mesures qui sont mises en place ici
entre autres on interdit désormais les
rassemblements de plus de 250 personnes
ça donc mené ici dans la province à
l'annulation de plusieurs événements
également on recommande évidemment
britanno-colombien d'éviter tout voyage
non essentiel et au retour au pays de se
mettre en isolement volontaire si
possible alors on a parlé de tout ça
aujourd'hui avec un effet
selon lui nous parle de mesures qui sont
très prudentes et selon lui la solution
surtout bassa réside dans le fait de
faire davantage de tests de dépistage
ce qui nous manque maintenant c'est des
données sur l'étendue de l'épidémie mais
pour ça il va falloir faire de plus en
plus de dépistages je pense que c'est là
qu'on doit insister pour la semaine à
venir
puis c'est un cas est dépisté d'abord en
place des mesures de santé publique
urgente et il n'est pourtant pas
question de fermer les écoles
encore un but quand annick pas pour
l'instant de marie mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'à partir de ce soir
il ya la majorité des élèves de la
province qui débutent leur période de
relâche scolaire est ici dans la
province pour bien des gens ça dure deux
semaines alors ce que dit le
gouvernement les autorités c'est que
pour l'instant il ya des discussions qui
sont en cours
on réfléchit à la possibilité de fermer
éventuellement les écoles tout ça
évidemment selon l'évolution des choses
et de la situation ici dans la province
mais également au pays
merci beaucoup qui merci à tous les cas
merci david s'est passé et où elle
domine merci beaucoup au revoir
alors me devais poursuivre avec vos
questions avec mes invités le docteur
alain poirier qui est dans notre studio
à sherbrooke rabon soir de temps poirier
je crois qu'on vous a retrouvé mon soir
pascale brillon psychologue et doctor
sursis le camp des microbiologistes je
vous lance à d'abord une question de
marcel gauthier est possible d'avoir une
mise à jour concernant les essais
pratiques des divers médicaments que les
scientifiques ont expédié en chine et
des différents travaux sur l'élaboration
d'un vaccin
on semble très impatient de reprendre
les deux de connaître l'avancement des
recherches des travaux bien les travaux
avancent rapidement ce qui concerne les
vaccins y trois axes un candidat qui
vont débuter en essais cliniques dans le
prochain mois
ceci dit ça prend toujours du temps les
évaluer ça prend deux phases une phase
d'une phase droit donc plusieurs mois
avant qu'on arrive à nant trouver un qui
risque d'être efficaces et qu'on puisse
déployer largement pour ce qui est des
médicaments il ya aussi des études qui
sont au fait en chine y plusieurs essais
cliniques
on a essayé différents médicaments 4,5
médicaments différents dont certains
semblent peut-être avoir une activité au
moins un laboratoire contre les souches
de grenat virus et on ne saura pas avant
plusieurs semaines
moi s'ils sont vraiment efficaces chez
les patients aux accords dernier pour le
moment la conférence tant il rien à
court terme qu'il faut surtout se méfier
de ce qui circule sur l'internet des
gens qui veulent vous vendre des
soi-disant des médicaments ou des
produits le qui seraient actifs contre
les coronavirus c'est pas le cas de
temps pour y ait un mot peut-être en
réaction avec qui a été mentionnée ici
au québec
david nous apprend que les tests de
dépistages vont augmenter que la ligne
pau si bien fonctionné
qu'est ce que vous dites aux
téléspectateurs qui veulent en savoir
plus sur leur état de santé oms et le
droit de réclamer dépistage et dans
quelles circonstances notamment
mais comme on sait il n'ya pas de
transmission locale donc il devrait pas
y avoir je le dire tant d'appels eu tant
de gens qui vont réclamer mais quand
est-ce qu'on peut le réclamer au moment
où nous quand nous arrive l'extérieur
ben c'est le premier critère avons-nous
voyager sommes nous à l'intérieur des
quatorze jours de l'incubation saisir du
développement du virus dans le corps et
ton des symptômes de fièvre température
janeiro donc ça pour l'instant ce sont
les critères le jour où il y aura de la
transmission reconnu identifier ici
belle à la nation du voyage on
recherchera plutôt avez vous contacté
rencontre que des jamais donc il faut
constamment ses indications les ajuster
mais en date d'aujourd'hui ça peut
vraiment beaucoup changé mais ça va
augmenter d'avesnes nous dire que c'est
la fin du mois les tests de dépistage à
l'augmenter qu'on avait déployé de
nouvelles cliniques à travers le québec
exactement c'est un nouveau test et il
faut la plupart de nos grands centres ce
pays sont capables de faire ce type de
test là mais il faut bien ajuster la
technologie on se rappelle qu'outre au
début même de notre laboratoire national
de santé publique du valider chaque test
à winnipeg
maintenant que c'est bien que la
rivalité d'ailleurs toutes les provinces
ont fait comme ça mais là encore mon
transfert
les appareils sont pas toujours les
mêmes donc est-ce que ce qu'on a
développé au laboratoire de santé
publique parce qu'on adule développés on
doit des cas tremblay connaît bien soin
de piloter le laboratoire de santé
publique met donc le développement de
tesla est ce que c'est lui même apparaît
donc il ya un défi de faire que d'autres
s'en vont de
les plus de capacité pour l'instant il
ya des centaines de collaborateurs à 100
publique mais en ajoutant les autres
laboratoires
on va avoir des milliers de possibilités
de départ jaune très bien madame meyer
dans la pose d'une brève pause et en
avoir d'autres questions du public il ya
tellement de choses qui ont été dites
depuis le début de cette heure vous
cette inquiétude de les comportements
aussi ont jamais entendu les gens nous
dire à quel point les gens sont venus
les épiceries puis ça manifeste cette
inquiétude là oui je pense que s'ils
veulent entendre c'est habituel c'est un
enfant qu'on voit ça c'est inhabituel
mais c'est aussi courant l'a vu dans
tous les autres pays où ça s'est produit
donc on n'est pas anormaux par rapport
aux autres pays par contre je pense
qu'il faut entendre cette inquiétude de
la population mettre des mesures en
place pour augmenter notre résistance et
notre résilience social comme je disais
plus tôt
et puis peut-être faire une grande
distinction je pense qu'il ya une
confusion social sûr on ferme des écoles
entre ça et l'isolément personnel
préventif l'isolément personnel curatif
et la quarantaine collective telle que
vécue en italie et je pense que ces
quatre termes là on était très mélangées
dans la population les gens ont tout de
suite interprété les mesures mises en
place par le gouvernement comme étant
une possibilité de quarantaine aussi
strictes que celles qu'on voit l'italie
alors que ce n'est pas du tout le cas
je pense qu'il reste
beaucoup d'informations a donné pour les
voir augmenter cette résilience et pour
aplanir la fameuse courbe
oui on va l'utiliser souvent de
personnes la servir la courbe alors
merci
alors on parle de quarantaine justement
d'isolement comment vivre la nouvelle
situation comment vous accompagner dans
cette nouvelle réalité que ton plutôt
faire pour vous et surtout quand on
pense aux employeurs aux compagnies et
aux droits et des travailleurs notamment
effacés
[Musique]
obligé de forcer des vacances est ce que
on va autres chômage comment que
l'argent va rentrer je pense ça commence
et un gros stress
d'abord le programme doit être annoncée
rapidement puis voté cab immédiatement
seront pas dans une situation là qui met
qui mettraient leurs familles à risque
financièrement on va avoir des mesures
de relance fiscales du niveau fiscal ça
c'est très important pour assurer les
gens qui vont avoir l'argent nécessaire
de continuer d'être dans une bonne
position pour eux et leur famille
alors que quelques extraits des annonces
du jour là mais des finances de l'ue
morneau qui annonçait donc des mesures
économiques pour permettre au canada de
faire face à la pandémie
le gouvernement en place un programme de
facilitation du crime de 10 milliards de
dollars pour soutenir des entreprises la
banque du canada annonce une diminution
du taux directeur qui pèse 1,25 à 1,75
est-ce que ce sera suffisant quel est le
point de vue des employeurs est aussi
quels sont les droits les attentes des
employés deux invités à québec
yves-thomas dorval bonsoir monsieur
dorval vous êtes président et chef de la
direction du conseil du patronat du
québec à montréal à nos côtés marianne
le monde on avocate en droit du travail
et présidente sortant de leur des
conseillers en ressources humaines
disque avec vous sommes à l'abandon
alors j'ai commencé avec vous monsieur
dorval à québec quand les mesures
annoncées tant à québec qu'à ottawa pour
le moment vous inspire-t-elle confiance
pour l'avenir donc est tellement
incertain malgré tout un pas dans la
bonne direction de voirie les
informations au niveau de l'aide aux
employés aux entreprises annoncés par le
fédéral en début de semaine plus de
nouveaux programmes en matière de
garantie curé ou des docks rieti il est
la baisse du taux directeur bien sûr
mais il y aura d'autres éléments ou
d'autres programmes qui vont suivre et
au québec là on s'attarde davantage pour
commencer à la priorité c'est à dire les
questions de prévention de précaution en
matière de santé publique
il a tu les entreprises dans le fond
dont trois roues ayant un rôle comme
entreprise de de produire et de fournir
des produits et des services à des
clients dans comment je peux assurer la
continuité de mes opérations
lorsqu'on citoyen beaucoup d'absentéisme
et que la clientèle diminue deuxièmement
il ya une responsabilité sociale je
dirais même une solidarité sociale
comment les employeurs et le milieu de
travail peut être solidaire pour
participer justement pour aux mécanismes
de prévention de précaution concernant
la en matière de santé publique mais
trois seulement il ya aussi des
responsabilités importantes en termes de
normes du travail mais surtout santé
sécurité au travail pour assurer des
milieux de travail
le st icq et monsieur
legault le premier ministre hier même
ces thérapies aujourd'hui appelé les
employeurs les patrons à être
compréhensif
est ce que ça veut dire payer des
salaires même si leur entrepôt de
service ça va jusqu'où dans votre esprit
vous êtes prêts allez jusqu'où pour
vivre en solidarité avec les employés
ensuite le chaque employeur une
situation particulière comme je vous dis
d'abord une question de droits et
d'obligations et de responsabilité mais
au-delà de ça les employeurs vont
nécessairement et c'est ce qu'il aurait
suggéré de part et d'autre les pdg sont
très au courant de ça c'est de faire la
demande en pâtit bien sûr de
compréhension et de flexibilité pour
essayer d'accommoder de toute façon les
employeurs sont aux prises avec des
obligations de continuité de services
dont ils ont tout intérêt et c'est ici
ce qu'ils font ont tout intérêt à faire
en sorte de de protéger et à aider leurs
mains des ressources humaines pour faire
en sorte d'éviter le plus possible les
enjeux de production qui va y avoir et
indéniablement vous avez une secteur
extrêmement touchée alors veille à des
demandes qu'on ne formulait encore
aujourd'hui on a envoyé nos demande au
fédéral et au provincial parce qu'on
consulte régulièrement nos membres sur
différents types d'interventions qui
devrait être fair qui vont bien au delà
de ce qui est fait à ce moment ci a
toujours un considérant qu' ils ont un
rôle aussi de responsabilités dont la
première responsabilité ont vu la santé
publique c'est s'assurer que leurs
activités ne contribuant pas à la
propagation d'un match des russes au
niveau de la communauté
alors madame d'abandon de votre côté
quelles sont vos attentes face aux
employeurs dans le but
2-2 bien-être des employés pour qu'ils
vivent énormément d'inquiétude notamment
quant à leurs salaires et autres respect
de leur rémunération du premier élément
a évidemment fait la communication les
employeurs s'ils veulent bien traverser
cette crise là on s'entend que des
enjeux financiers très importants pour
certains employeurs dans certains
secteurs
donc c'est très important de communiquer
les choses très clairement donc par
exemple le fait que l'hygiène devient
vraiment une obligation obligation de se
laver les mains quand on arrive au
milieu de travail de façon sporadique on
sort dîner on revient on se lave les
mains on doit passer par le lavabo
donc ce genre de choses là on est rendu
là d'abord évidemment le matériel pour
ce déjeuner tous à désinfecter davantage
le milieu de travail aussi mais aussi
évidemment éviter tout tout tout voyage
à l'extérieur du canada
et pour ce qui est des voyages
personnels parce que c'est quand même
une question qui revient chez les hommes
meurent à l'heure actuelle évidemment à
quelqu'un qui décide d'aller à
l'étranger malgré tout ce qu'on a
entendu et les directives très claires
du gouvernement au fait qu'on a eu on
déconseille un employeur et justifiées à
ce stade-ci de déconseiller fortement le
voyage à l'étranger ici la personne
revient c'est à ses risques et périls
parce qu'elle va devoir être mis en
quarantaine c'est pas clair qu'il va
pouvoir toucher son salaire si on comme
monsieur normalisée c'est un cas
d'espèce la cha cha cha cha cun aurait
chaque employé c'est chacun un code
différents mais cela dit ça peut durer
longtemps parce que si la personne
appréciée présentent des symptômes est
peut-être parti pour une quarantaine
d'un mois il est donc dans ces
circonstances là évidemment les
employeurs pourront peau
prendre fait et cause pour ses employés
locaux qui ont décidé de quitter le pays
par ailleurs tout événement conférences
colloques réunions mais ne devrait être
annulé à moins que ce soit nécessaire et
on devrait procéder le plus possible par
appels vidéo conférence de façon à
éviter tout rassemblement de toutes
natures les employeurs devraient aussi
donner la directive que tout
rassemblement même au niveau personnel
est fortement déconseillé de façon à
cause du mariage par exemple peuvent en
outre 125 éviter que ce que tu fais
c'est quand même hautement problématique
et on peut s'attendre qu'il va y avoir
des absents lorsque vous jouez pas les
gens ont plus goût de se retrouver avec
des problèmes après parce qu'une fois
qu'on est infecté avant de revenir au
travail on parle plus juste de deux
semaines
non pas dans ce processus au complet
jusqu'à temps qu'on l'ait sûr parce
qu'évidemment pour report et intégrer
n'importe qui dans le milieu de travail
sauf lors que la personne elle est une
preuve de test négatif ou encore kelly
un certificat médical d'aptitude au
travail autrement leur rêve aurait
intégré des gens qui sont peut-être
infectés que sont vos craintes monsieur
dorval façon quelles sont vos craintes
de dorval face à vos avold
ça va à vos employés la première des
choses ne collait du sirpa parlé
abondamment de plusieurs mesures
la première dès qu'un essai c est ce que
je garde mon milieu de travail sain et
sécuritaire c'est ma première
responsabilité à l'égard des emplois et
mes clients alors qu'est ce que je fais
pour ça donc la première préoccupation
c'est de s'assurer qu'ils soient au
courant des situations qui s'est pas
facile à gérer parce qu'il faut poser
des questions parfois et puis on peut
pas poser des questions sur le poids des
doses raisonnables par ya plein
d'éléments complexes quand même à gérer
mais comme on dit tantôt la transparence
dans la communication c'est l'anglais et
l'envoya doit avoir une transparence
dans sa communication des employés doit
avoir une transparence dans la
communication avec l'employeur mais je
le dis il ya des secteurs industriels et
des secteurs de l'économie actuellement
sont aux prises non seulement avec des
problèmes de présence ou qui vont avoir
des problèmes à partir de la semaine
prochaine
mais je vais vous que toutes les écoles
les systèmes de les garderies ferme
que va-t-il arriver avec les employés
qui ont déjà des enjeux à gérer du côté
sadique des mails à devoir s'occuper
aussi de leur famille il ya une grande
crainte sur la capacité d'assurer la
continuité de service d'une part d'autre
part il ya des industries qui sont là
touchée de manière majeure par cette
foule industrie du tourisme alors pensé
1re transporteur est rien vous avez
entendu il y aurait tout à l'heure face
aux hôtels pense au centre des congrès
pense aux événements toutes les régions
l'industrie touristique c'est un élément
extrêmement important pourquoi les
régions divers encore si cet exemple la
production agroalimentaire c'est la même
chose on doit assurer la fourniture des
aliments des dangers pour la population
alors comment offert au niveau de la
production de la distribution et de la
vente et même de production et en plus
de ça là on avait bientôt à la période
des semis que l'on peut s'assurer
d'avoir la main d'oeuvre pour faire les
semis parce qu'il ya toute la question
des migrations au niveau de ses amis en
effet et donc
et pour vous demander en terminant très
rapidement monsieur dorval les mesures
économiques de deux pour faire des prêts
pour les deux gouvernements ont dit
qu'ils seraient là pour soutenir tout le
monde vous y croyez vous avez confiance
ce message est clair je pense que les
gouvernements on sait très bien où tout
début de la question de santé publique
et au départ les deuxièmes dans il ya
beaucoup beaucoup à faire
parce qu ils pas énormément de dommage
il faut assurer des revenus temps aux
employés qui seront absents que pour les
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
continuer à assumer leur productivité
leur production merci monsieur de
revenir sur l'abandon est bien
évidemment ailleurs dans le monde
l'ethiopie le kenya et le ghana ont
rapporté leurs premiers cas de nombreux
pays emboîtent le pas avec des mesures
exceptionnelles voici quelques unes des
nouvelles de cette autre journée de
pandémie résumé en 60 secondes
nous allons faire passer cette limite au
rassemblement 200 personnes
du rop has now because i épi center of
de pandemic with more report
[Musique]
notre pays
dans notre chambre déclare l'état
d'urgence et des lacunes dans la gestion
de la crise aux etats unis restent avec
nous on va faire les autres
[Musique]
alors le président antoine
car aujourd'hui l'état d'urgence aux
épaisses de livres qu'il est il par
prendre au sérieux cette pandémie
prendra lisez donc la gestion de
l'administration de forme je jouais à
sherbrooke carrément politologue à
l'université de sherbrooke ont soit 40
vraiment bon soir alors écoutez dites
moi on a entendu hier le patron de cdc
monsieur farouche bon la pendule extrait
le dire aussi en échec le dépistage
aujourd'hui monsieur crom qui exhibe un
don balon ce pas un échec on est les
meilleurs vins bières et disait on au
juste content de mort alors qu'elle
avait 38 votre regard à votre évaluation
de la gestion de la crise passe est une
très mauvaise gestion de crise c'est une
gestion de crise qui a mis beaucoup de
temps à se mettre en branle
on se rappelle au début il ya quelques
semaines choc minimiser cette crise là
en disant fière un vaccin bientôt faut
pas paniquer
très peu de cas aux états unis c'est
peut-être des gens son entourage disait
à l'époque c'est peut-être même un
canular démocrate ou en tout cas c'est
une crise amplifié par les démocrates or
évidemment là on a comme un mois de
retard le à partir de ce moment là parce
qu'on sait que le premier cas est
apparue probablement fin janvier début
février alors ses prêteurs le pur pour
gérer une crise de cette ampleur là les
mesures on doit être prise de façon un
peu aléatoire le par les villes par les
états en l'absence de réaction de du
fédéral hélas aujourd'hui enfin là on
annonce cet état d'urgence avec
évidemment ce qui vient avec c'est à
dire des ressources financières humaines
et l'autorité nécessaire pour mettre en
place des mesures peut-être plus adéquat
on l'espère est ce que vous avez senti
que monsieur jobs avait plus à coeur
dans le fond l'économie que la santé des
américains parce que quand on révélait
les lacunes les faiblesses du système
notamment de dépistage la fin de
certains programmes justement pour
contrer les pandémies les épidémies
monsieur thiam dit aujourd'hui
maintenant je connais pas ça je suis
commence pas de ma faute si ça a été
abandonnée ce programme là il renvoie
tout ça aux autres et envoie aux autres
il a accusé barack obama aussi où son
administration d'avoir changé les règles
de réaction autrement dit aux crises
alors que quand on se rappelle du h1n1
il y avait un million de personnes qui
avaient été testées dans le premier mois
là aux états unis on n'a pas vraiment
les chiffres et c'est ce qui est
inquiétant quand même à l'heure actuelle
mais on parle les experts parlent de
moins de 10000 personnes qui ont été
testées probablement à l'heure actuelle
adjointe a mis du temps à réagir à cette
créé justement pour des raisons
économiques comme vous dites
parce que à chaque fois qu'elle a créé
s'envenimait la bourse plonger et on
sait à quel point pour trump il prend
soin personnel quand la bourse plonger
et donc qu'il essayait de minimiser un
peu l'impact que ça pouvait avoir en
termes économiques mais là avec le
projet de loi de la chambre ketchup a
semble-t-il à prouver je sais pas encore
las les républicains de la chambre l'ont
soutenu pour l'instant mais mais ça
permet justement de regarnir les coffres
de medicaid pour justement permettre aux
gens détester et ça ça devrait aider
aussi et est ce que vous croyez que
l'impact de sa gestion de crise sur sa
popularité et ses chances de réélection
tout dépend de la durée de la crise
évidemment si elle devait se résorber
rapidement peut-être que il aurait le
temps du 6 novembre
de rétablir un peu sa cote de popularité
mais c'est sûr que pour l'instant c'est
difficile pour lui il gère pas bien
cette crise là et la suite il y ait plus
de parti politique quand on est affecté
au niveau de la santé quand les gens se
demandent s'ils ont les moyens de rester
à la maison qu'ils soient malades ou pas
évidemment on peut comprendre que ça a
un impact peut-être sur la personne
qu'ils jugent responsables de cette
crise là et si ça devait s'envenimer
évidemment on peut imaginer que ça
aurait un impact sur les zones aussi on
verra aussi si ça se sent ça dure dans
le temps mais comment commencer cette
élection là se tiendra ou paul faudra
faudra sûrement rediscuter aussi parce
que tout change dans la campagne
électorale est ce que monsieur tron
voyons en étant privé de ses grands
rallyes qu'ils rendent si effervescence
pour accuser tout le monde et faire
valoir ses idées c'est son plein on est
les meilleurs là alors tout comme du
change
on peut penser que c'est c'est une arme
en moins pour lui là ça peut l'affecter
de ce point de vue là non ça peut
l'affecter parce que pour lui ça
fonctionne bien c'est grand rallye là et
ils risquent peut-être d'être plus actif
sur twitter dans les prochaines semaines
alors faudra surveiller peut-être encore
plus de plus près ce qui va dire sur
twitter parce que ce sera à peu près
tout ce qui va lui rester évidemment ce
moment là et les démocrates dans tout ça
comment peuvent-ils tirer leur épingle
du jeu parce que grand débat chez les
démocrates notamment de la part de
brennus en deux sur l'importance d'avoir
un système de santé universel
est ce que cette crise n'est pas
justement révélateur des des besoins
clients aux états unis pour un système
de santé que je suis accessible et
pourquoi pas universelle tout à fait je
pense que bernie sanders a vraiment une
fenêtre d'opportunité malgré malgré le
côté sombre de cette affaire-là parce
que on démontre par l'exemple concret la
nécessité d'obtenir un système de santé
qui permet aux gens de postes poser de
questions il y en a combien d'américains
qui n'ont pas été se faire tester ces
dernières semaines parce qu'ils disaient
j'ai pas les moyens nécessairement d'y
aller alors que là avec avec le projet
de loi qui est proposé on va permettre
aux gens de certains sites et peu
importe ils ont une assurance ou pas
mais ça va permettre à 102,2 justement
plus plus facilement clarifier son
message
et dire vous voyez comme on en a besoin
en particulier dans les situations de
crise mais en tous cas
et évidemment il ya joe biden aussi qui
a fait un discours assez remarqué il ya
quelques jours qu'ils étaient discours
rassembleur qui est un discours de chef
d'état en fait qui tentait de rassurer
tout le monde
mais encore une fois on verra l'impact
que ça va en novembre c'est encore très
loin novembre alors on verra qui n'est
pas que ça pourrait avoir sur les gens
mais on a vu par exemple que la
louisiane avait décidé de reporter son
élection primaire l'a repoussée en juin
alors qu'il devait avoir lieu en avril
si d'autres états devaient faire la même
chose mais là on pourrait peut-être se
poser un peu plus de questions sur le
momentum des démocrates à l'heure
actuelle
oui parce qu'un débat dimanche soir de
monsieur sein de leur choix sans public
sans public en même temps on voit ce
qu'ils pensaient que monsieur 112 annulé
ou aurait se serait retiré de la course
on peut être déçu mais la lsq il reste
là pour défendre ses idées quel ton
savoir ce que ça va être important ce
débat-là par le contexte actuel où il ya
une si grande inquiétude aux écoles et
aux états unis lé parce que c'est la
panique loppsi c'est la panique je pense
que c'est un débat important ne serait
ce que parce ce sera le premier avec
seulement deux personnes déjà ça peut
être intéressant ce point de vue là mais
ça va devoir aussi quelles solutions
concrètes ces deux ans me propose aux
américains dans le code de la comédie
n'est bien sûr mais plus largement en
termes de santé je pense que ça va être
au coeur du débat du 15 assurément très
bien merci beaucoup
karine prénom on sort par la semaine
prochaine au revoir merci au revoir jean
tout mon panel d'experts alain poirier à
sherbrooke pascale veillon à montréal et
deux classes à celle tremblay également
à montréal une question très concrète
c'est chez matériaux qui la pose quelles
sont les possibilités qu'on se retrouve
en isolement avant longtemps et dans
l'impossibilité de sortir pour
s'apprivoiser s'approvisionner je crois
que c'est une question que beaucoup de
personnes ont en tête et c'est pour ça
qu'on voit cette course là dans les
épiceries puis qu'on achète des tonnes
de rouleau de papier de toilette pas
pourquoi le bain en fait je pense que
c'est un symbole de
de se sentir sécuritaire et de faire
quelque chose de concret pour se
préparer
les chances que les gens se retrouvent
en isolement volontaire présentement
sont pas très grandes
mais au fur et à mesure que l'épidémie
se développe si elle se développe avec
beaucoup de transmissions
éventuellement il va avoir plusieurs
personnes qui vont être en isolement
volontaire mais ceci dit l'isolément
volontaire c'est 14 jours si on est
atteint par la maladie ça risque d'être
un petit peu plus long un maximum un
mois à peu près donc quand les gens vont
à l'épicerie qui font leurs provisions
faut garder la même logique qu est ce qu
on a besoin qui en général dans nos
maisons ont fait des épiceries puis on a
de quoi manger pour jusqu'à une semaine
alors entre ya lippi remplir les paniers
de toutes sortes de choses qu'on donne
aux besoins ou la logique de dire bon je
fais une épicerie puis j'en fais un
petit peu plus je m'assure d'avoir
suffisamment de médicaments de
prescription pour un mois sur ce qu'une
bonne conduite de toute façon que les
gens devraient faire je pense qu'il faut
que les gens avant de partir pour
l'épicerie réfléchissez un peu puisque
disent ok je me préparais mais qu'est ce
que j'ai vraiment besoin
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on craint aussi
la quarantaine collective et les gens
craignent de ne pas pouvoir sortir ya
une différence avec isolement volontaire
dont parlait peut-être envie de dire et
je moi je me nomme et mon entourage non
venez me porter des provisions je peux
me faire livrer des choses à la maison
et pendant ce temps la vie continue à
fonctionner et on est très très loin de
penser qu'on va arrêter la ville
complètement en arrêtant tous les
marchés des épiceries et que personne
parce qu'il va voir larminat commenté
dit par exemple exactement à essayer
c'est ça qui est important aussi de
saisir si on est en isolement seul à la
maison et on peut se faire livrer les
choses voyez aujourd'hui un restaurant
qui propose être à livrer des choses et
le bonus était le rouleau de papier
toilette c'est très mignon mais il va
encore on voit des possibilités de
pouvoir voir un contact minimale du
moins avec des denrées
et non pas de se sentir qu'on est
vraiment dans une prison dont on ne peut
pas se reposer ses sapeurs la date
employés là dessus ben écoutez je vais
presque un fou rire en écoutant on va
pas laisser mourir les gens truffé de
soif ou demande de papier de toilette
parce qu'ils sont en isolement et or
comme on vient de le dire la question
livraisons il ya aussi était là il y
aura tellement peu de monde dans les
rues qu'en portant un masque en
isolement
je pense qu'il y aura toutes sortes de
façons de s'approvisionner avec les amis
qui sont pour bon scénario en faire ma
vie complètement calme le pompon dans un
scénario où on ferme les villes comme ça
a été le cas en chine et en italie
les magasins les épiceries rester
ouverts les fairness restés ouverts et
les gens étaient autorisés à aller
chercher de la nourriture alors moi j'ai
une belle fille dont la famille chinoise
puis dans leur ville tout était fermé
mais c'était interdit fermé des
épiceries et les pharmacies les gens
pouvaient y aller un parent chercher
leurs enfants
cette même si on se retrouvait dans une
situation aussi dramatique que l'italie
book ou clash et nook la france il y
aurait des solutions pour la population
donc ce qu'on me dit dr poirier calmons
nous alors on s'en va une prose vos
projets de voyage sont chamboulées que
devez vous faire maintenant quelles sont
les réponses dans quelques instants puis
aussi la question des assurances
on en parle brièvement par la pause
[Musique]
ottawa demande aux canadiens de reporter
ou d'annuler lé tout voyage à
l'extérieur du canada qui n'est pas
essentiel sa demande avait déjà été
suggérée d'ailleurs fortement par québec
vous nous avez inondé de questions sur
les remboursements possible on vous
offre quelques plus de réponse avec deux
invités charles tanguay porte parole de
l'office de la protection du
consommateur qui est à québec bonsoir
monsieur tanguay bon il y eut même
présidente pour le québec de
l'association canadienne des compagnies
d'assurances de personnes bonsoir madame
alors c'est julie monde qui va vous
lancez les questions mais je vous
annonce quelques unes des gens rafale
qui sont entrés très très très nombreux
ces questions qui nous arrive sur les
réseaux sociaux également dans la boîte
coréen de 24,60 l'une des questions
qu'on nous demande c'est est ce qu'on
doit éviter à tout prix de prendre
l'avion même à l'intérieur du pays ou à
l'intérieur de la province par exemple
on pense à certains vols assez important
dans lesquelles il y aurait plus de 250
personnes à l'intérieur de l'appareil
donc une première question la seconde
que je vous lance son deuxième piste
comment at on prévu accueillir les
milliers de québécois de snowbirds a qui
sont présentement en floride où ailleurs
dans le sud des états unis et qui seront
de retour dans quelques semaines à peine
une arrivée massive à prévoir au doigt
mais également pour leur mise en
quarantaine ou en isolement donc comment
avons-nous prévu accueillir ces
vacanciers
troisième piste de réflexion pour vous
on sait que les états unis ont fermé
donc les barrières les douanes pour les
voyageurs arrivant d'europe
est ce que le canada va faire quelque
chose pour ces gens justement qui
pourrait par exemple transité par notre
pays en terminant est-ce qu'on veut
prévoir remboursés d'une quelconque
façon compensé les voyageurs qui avaient
acheté des séjours des voyages et des
formules bref toutes sortes de forfaits
pour des destinations qui ne sont pas
nécessairement des conseillers mais donc
pour lesquelles ces personnes pourraient
être plus frileuses plus craintive
d'effectuer quand même le voyage donc
voilà un mari pour vos invités quatre
questions en rafale comme le toutes les
destinations sont déconseillés il ya une
dimension santé une dimension plus
commercial je vais commencer sur la
question de la santé à quelques
questions en rafale de tremblay prête
nous y rapidement de quoi il s'agit
prendre l'avion c'est c'est déconseillé
c'est déconseillé de prendre l'avion
même si
la santé publique du canada donne d'ipad
ne t'en dis pas les voyages à
l'intérieur du pays
je pense qu'il faut utiliser son gros
bon sens puis je dire que dans le fond
de voyager de montréal à vancouver c'est
plus loin que le voyage est de marier
mais bien et on le rappellera nul est
d'être un certain temps alors de votre
côté de côté les assurances les gens
s'inquiètent de perdre leur leur mise
pour un voyage et devrait y renoncer a
fait l'addition de voyage et je pense
qu'on a des experts ici pour ce qui est
du remboursement en fait il ya
différents types de polices d'assurance
par exemple et des polices d'assurance
annulation toutes conditions comme ces
produits particuliers généralement les
gens peuvent annuler sans avoir de
justification mais la plupart des
polices que les gens en c'est pour des
raisons d'ordre médical ou parce qu'il
ya un avis de niveau 3 ou plus qui a été
déclaré par le gouvernement et qu'on est
là dedans c'est sur la question présente
mort si je faisais ce matin je vous
aurais dit ça prend un niveau 3 ou plus
pour qu'il y ait possibilité de se faire
rembourser
puisque nous nous lie police dans le
contrat on se base sur des avis objectif
du gouvernement
le problème auquel on fait face
présentement c'est que monsieur trudeau
a fait une annonce aujourd'hui et on
nous dit éviter tout voyage non
essentiel sans avoir changé
la cote de risque du pays donc
nous on nous sommes à analyser cette
situation et à prendre une position cdu
on est en terrain est complètement
inconnu alors ça va être du cas par cas
selon son assureur j'imagine de votre
côté monsieur tanguay québec quelle
ville l'office de protection du
consommateur
alors va de notre côté on a un cadre les
agents de voyages avec la loi sur les
agents de voyages et le fonds
d'indemnisation des clients des agents
de voyages qui prévoit justement un peu
comme dans le cas de l'assurance
la possibilité d'annuler un voyage et de
se faire entièrement remboursée dans le
cas où un avis officiel du gouvernement
fédéral recommanderait d'éviter tout
voyage non essentiel
or justement en fin de journée ou en
milieu de journée aujourd'hui le
gouvernement fédéral lance est que
maintenant l'avis en question ou
l'avertissement en question visaient
tous les pays
alors vraisemblablement le fonds
d'indemnisation pourra rembourser tous
les voyages achetés d'un agent de voyage
et c'est ça la des salaires quand la
condition principale et là je présume
que bien des téléspectateurs vont se
rendre compte de l'importance de faire
affaire avec une agence de voyages et de
l'utilité de cette protection là alors
effectivement les gens qui ont acheté
avant l'avertissement ça c'est important
et dont le voyage doit avoir lieu alors
que l'avertissement sera toujours en
vigueur c'est ce que si votre voyage et
dans six mois
il est trop tôt pour vous dire que vous
serez remboursé à 100% puisque on ne
sait pas dans six mois si les
avertissements ne seront pas levés il
c'est la même chose pour les croisières
le gouvernement fédéral décommandé ou
même recommandé de ne pas participer à
des croisières alors ça rentre
maintenant dans cette catégorie de deux
critères pour
remboursement par le fonds
d'indemnisation des clients des agents
notant que la date de la croisière soit
arrivé que l'avertissement soit toujours
en vigueur à la date en question est
alors soit vous met ensemble tous les
deux les assureurs et l'office de la
protection du consommateur lui parle
bien des agences de voyages
mais tous ceux ou celles qui ont acheté
des voyages par internet comme c'est la
grande mode ça passait par un agent de
voir un pic se sont acheté aussi par
internet une assurance voyage son temps
les assureurs ont peu pris une position
claire ça ça pourrait être une position
nationale de tous les assureurs ensemble
qui pourrait considérer comme le dit
monsieur tanguy a loupé c'est que c'est
un niveau assez élevé pour rembourser
est-ce qu'on fait présentement c'est que
en fait mon association et canadiennes
on représente tous les assureurs qui
font affaire au canada et on tente de
développer des bonnes pratiques pour que
dans la mesure du possible les québécois
et les canadiens sachent à quoi
s'attendre alors c'est notre objectif
mais un de nos enjeux principaux c'est
que la situation change d'heure en heure
au début de la semaine on a changé de
jour en jour mais maintenant la
situation change d'heure en heure donc
c'est la difficulté à laquelle un
faisons face mais pour l'instant il n'y
a pas de trop d'espoir de rembourser
tout le monde s'ils sont passées par
internet et pas par une agence en fait
le site c'est de savoir comment qu'est
ce qu'on va faire avec la déclaration où
la poussée du gouvernement à l'effet que
nous devons éviter tout voyage essentiel
alors que la façon que ça fonctionne
dans les contrôles dans plusieurs
contrats d'assurance voyage pour obtenir
une annulation
il faut que le pays ait la cote de 3 au
niveau de son risque en deux trois
quatre
donc ça doit être une cause de trop
cadeau qu'on est en train d'étudier les
raisons puisqu'elle assure recourir
est ce que vous pourriez généreux c'est
à dire pas contribuer à l'effort
économique qui s'adonnent à tout le
monde de dire ben écoutez la cote trois
là c'est ici que ça se passe
on veut pas que les canadiens s'en aille
dans un pays où il pourrait pas être
soigné pas parce que le pays dangereux
mais parce que s'ils développent la
maladie a été dit on d'un système de
santé auquel ils n'ont pas accès à l'eau
tout à fait que je peux vous dire que
nous voulons dans ce dossier dans cette
crise est un partenaire du gouvernement
on travaille très fort avec le
gouvernement fédéral pour une
coordination avec les prestations
d'assurance emploi pour que personne ne
se retrouve en deux chaises que les gens
soient ou elle soit des prestations
d'assurance-emploi ou de la santé
validité donc présentement il ya un
exercice de coordination
en tout les en tout cas les joueurs
entre le gouvernement les assureurs les
employeurs le fils de protection du
consommateur au niveau de vie est chère
ça pourrait coûter cher si on devait
payer tout à fait mais ça c'est déjà 10
pour une fois les assureurs vont payer
il ya une certaine méfiance aux
compagnies d'assurance et nous paye
jamais cassé de ta ouais mais si les
gens soient là et ils auront accès de
l'assurance invalidité donc il ya aussi
cet aspect là présentement qu'on regarde
très attentivement alors monsieur
poirier l'attend poirier à sherbrooke
avez vous une réflexion là dessus quand
on vous dit qu'on devait participer à
l'effort collectif et solidaire parce
que génère de l'angoissé aussi là oui
oui plutôt
moi même j'ai acheté un beau voyage
bientôt et toute la famille alors je
sais pas encore j'ai écouté mais c'est
pas un agent de voyage comme vous l'avez
dit c'est expédia c'est où
on est on sait maintenant comment alors
on
c'est un agent alban bonne nouvelle pour
moi mais bref je pense que pour pas mal
de gens qui doivent réfléchir moi
évidemment peut-être d'une mise sous son
peut aussi compter que la majorité des
gens mais mais le mont messages et
écouter l'importance et respecter les
consignes l'argent passera en deuxième
lieu mais faudra pour beaucoup d'autres
gens trouvez moi aussi je vais accepter
mais il faudra trouver des solutions
parce que c'est ça pose pour les 30
secondes de 4 ans blaise nombre ils vont
revenir pieds des gens qui vont revenir
plus tôt 1
alors les allemands elle ment et
quarantaine
mais ce c'est clair donc ce les gens ils
tentent préparer le terrain pour
recevoir la leurs parents leurs grands
parents qui reviennent de floride
et puis c'est mieux de revenir
maintenant ça serait mieux de revenir
maintenant parce qu'avant que lorsque la
grossesse
oui des risques la boisson plus grand
que les risques sont plus grands que
c'est en floride la situation ça évolue
à chaque jour alors c'est difficile de
tenir compte mais je pense que ce serait
bien de revenir ici comme ça ils seront
pas au coeur de la vieille les crises
merci beaucoup
alors merci monsieur tanguay québec
merci madame s beaucoup d'entre vous ont
servi la pause et après la pause où tu
poses littéraire albert camus et la ps
pourquoi serait intéressant de relire
cette oeuvre extraordinaire un grand
classique de la littérature martin
wenger est avec nous autour
[Musique]
on vous propose une pause littérature de
quelques minutes parce qu'en ces temps
de coronavirus un classique de la
littérature suscite vraiment un regain
d'intérêt
il créé en 1947 la peste d'albert camus
raconte la vie quotidienne des habitants
d'oran en algérie alors que la ville est
frappée par une épidémie de peste est
coupé du reste du monde les ventes de ce
célèbre roman sont en forte hausse
depuis le début de l'année 2020 ça
s'explique mais on veut comprendre
pourquoi alors j'accueille l'écrivain
martin venture qui est également médecin
alors bonsoir défi soit alors pourquoi
pourquoi la peste d'albert camus mais
parce que c'est un roman métaphorique
il n'a pas été il parle pas vraiment
d'une épidémie il parle de la france
occupée par par les nazis mais
finalement ce dont il parle c'est d'une
communauté qui est enfermé et qui ne
sait pas comment survivre à cette
maladie
cette peste noire qui ben question se
pose et sous la forme des rats qui
transporte la paix est malsaine l'état
ça c'est une métaphore est une métaphore
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est tous
enfermés dans le même lieu et qu'on est
menacé par par la même chose alors il
décrit plusieurs personnages et décrit
le docteur rieux qui est personnage
central du roman qui lui soigne des gens
qui sont malades
est-ce que c'est son c'est sa mission et
puis il y en a d'autres comme quotas
requis lui d'abord est extrêmement
perturbé qui ensuite profitent de la
misère des autres
et puis il ya ta roue qui vient aider le
docteur rieux
il ya un grand mère qui lui envie de
partir pour retrouver sa femme qui est à
l'extérieur on en fait il décrit
l'attitude de toutes les personnes
présentes
face à ce danger et c'est un roman qui
est écrit par un philosophe qui qui a
écrit le mythe de sisyphe c'est-à-dire
qu'ils parlent surdité de la vie et
finalement c'est un roman qui
montre comment les gens en face à une
difficulté charge du sens c'est
exactement ce que font les lecteurs et
les charges du sens dans leur bain parce
que c'est un roman qui parle de la
recherche du sens et le sens que camus
donne il donne tout au long du roman
mais ils le donnent aussi à la fin il
dit finalement on n'a que deux solutions
ou bien on s'enfuit ou en meurent aux
biens ont fait oeuvre collective pour
lutter contre le danger parce que c'est
la solidarité et le travail collectif
qui aura le plus de chance de sauver le
plus grand nombre de gens aient vraiment
transposer dans la pandémie actuelle
c'est de là qu'on peut transposer tout à
fait le sait ce qui est paradoxal dans
la pandémie actuelle c'est que on nous
demande de ne rien faire c'est à dire
que on nous demande du regret du monde
au lieu d'être actif et c'est paradoxal
parce qu'on est dans un monde dans
lequel on nous demande toujours de faire
des choses est là pour la première fois
on lui dit non il faut que vous restiez
chez vous que vous regardez vos
distances avec le monde
c'est ça qui va être protecteur c'est
paradoxal c'est un changement de
paradigme extraordinairement
nouveau quoi puis ça va absolument à
l'encontre de tout ce qui est recherche
de la croissance de la productivité du
profit à tout prix etc
mais moi je trouve ça tout à fait
intéressant que les gens aillent
chercher des réponses dans camus dit à
titre personnel un lien personnel j'ai
un lien personnel puisque mon père était
l'ami d'enfance d'albert camus la même
chose
il a même soigné il était médecin et il
a même soigné la mère de camille et il a
parlé avec camus de sa propre maladie
qui était la tuberculose donc c'est
c'est quelque chose qui moi me touche
beaucoup ce que la figure du médecin à
l'intérieur du livre c'est une figure
universelle de soignants le soignant
c'est la personne qui décide de ne pas
s'enfuir et de s'occuper des gens qui
souffrent il ya une belle phrase vers la
fin presque elle a fait la mort et la
vie nous sommes ensemble alamo et le mal
nous sommes ensemble pour pour les
combattre on les combat cru il faut être
ensemble pour les combattre en même
temps cette ce que l'on vit actuellement
risque de mettre à plat tout le système
social et économique en tout cas on ne
situe jamais vu il ya sauf peut-être à
faire des grandes gares et tout ça les
gens qui se questionnent la base comment
on voit ce qu'on va vivre après la maman
je crois que je crois que ce que ce que
ça va faire c'est que ça va stimuler
beaucoup l'imagination d'une part et les
initiatives c'est à dire que je pense
que le système actuel il est aussi
extrêmement verrouillé il empêche les
gens de faire des choses qui pourraient
faire mais on leur dit bao mais c'est
peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas assez
rentable c'est peut-être alors que là
précisément comme tout ce qui est
rentable va être ralenti il ya des
initiatives qui pourront se mettre en
place pour faire autre chose je pense
que en tout cas dans les pays développés
c'est une chance extraordinaire de
changer de paradigme et de proposer
d'autres moyens de fonctionner mais
manqué valeur principale
c'est vraiment pour vous ou c'est la
seule série la solidarité d'entraidé la
jeune originaire et entend attirer
délassant au moi je crois qu'on peut on
peut lui et quand vous voyez aller les
choses oui tout à fait l'arrière résiste
et socialement résister je suis en train
de lire un autre qui s'appelle les
parisiennes sur la vie des femmes à
paris pendant l'occupation
donc c'est serré hasard qu'on m'ait
demandé de relire la peste mais de ça va
très bien la résistance sociale c'est
précisément ça ne peut être que le fait
de la solidarité on peut selon peut
résister individuellement mais on peut
aussi résisté en étant plus gentil plus
accueillant on peut parler vous voyez on
va pas pouvoir toucher les gens et les
voir plus souvent
mais on peut parler on est dans un monde
dans lequel on peut communiquer c'était
pas le cas il ya 50 ans et sans la
manière d'un ton en gère les choses
actuellement comme un voyage compass je
compare la france le canada les états
unis et je trouve qu'on n'est pas mal
loti
on est c je lisais par exemple les la
commande du britannique a eu à faire ça
en eau début des années 2000 il était
complètement dépassés mais ils ont
appris et du coup ils ont appris au
reste du canada
comment faire face à ce genre de choses
intenses et la cale plus grand nombre de
cas c'est là qu'elles peuvent rendre le
cas parce que c'est là que ça arrive
merci martin winckler de nous avoir
invité à relire la peste pour ce qu'ils
ont dû moi ça fait pas mal d'années est
resté avec nous on considère après la
pause avec les invités sur le plateau a
tout de suite pour le mot de la fin
l'astag
[Musique]
le temps de conclure cette émission avec
des dernières questions de julie et de
vous quelques questions à marie en
rafale pour terminer justement entre
autres des petites ouvertures bon il ya
des gens qui se questionnent à savoir si
ça vaut la peine à ce que cet endroit si
la dans la crise de vraiment renforcer
son système immunitaire est ce qu'on
peut être mieux protégés justement pour
ne pas attraper la coved 19 si on y est
en contact avec quelqu'un qui serait à
contaminer justement est-ce que la
propagation du virus peut se faire dans
les conduites de ventilation d'aération
dans beaucoup de questions de gens qui
habitent dans des détours des résidences
des tours à condos par exemple dans la
queue du coup on se questionne si ça
peut circuler et enfin à ce que les
nettoyants à vapeur peuvent être utile
pertinent pour désinfecter les surfaces
vous lancer quelques questions merci
julie c'est à vous à la maison on y va
on va faire avec vous doivent d'abord
avec vous de faire trembler renforcer
son système immunitaire les rangs de
façon magique de renforcer son système
immunitaire en général si on mange bien
d'alimentation fait de l'exercice notre
système immunitaire devrait combattre
les maladies
je peux déjà émis nos supprimés et c'est
pas le temps de commencer à s'acheter
des galons vitamine c parce que ça
change rien vous allez juste les urines
et parce que si vous en manquez pas dans
votre système
ça a juste rien est-ce que ça se propage
par la ventilation on a toujours bien
dit que le virus se propage par
gouttelettes et par contact boucle
pourrait être proche de la personne pour
pouvoir être contaminés ventilation ce
serait si ce virus n'osent pas se
propagerait pas airs au sol ce qui n'est
pas le cas donc on ne crée pas par
rapport à la ventilation docteur vin
rosé
pendant la pause que si c'était arrivé
dans les croisiens de ventilation
partout si c'est pas service à tout le
monde on était malade pour vous docteur
poirier au début des travaux de la 10ème
mois g2g
deux obsessions aplanir la fameuse
courbe et laver les mains c'est le mot
allah le message a lancé oui mais moi je
rajouterais une autre rebondir sur la
question de la solidarité on est un
réseau de santé et de services sociaux
et dans toutes ces épidémies ces
problèmes la canicule c'est toujours les
plus vulnérables les personnes âgées les
gens qui vivent seuls qui vont avoir
besoin des d'alors au moment où on se
prépare nous acheter notre papier
toilette de faudrait peut-être penser
aux gens qui ont autour de nous devons
avoir des difficultés vont parfaitement
bien comprendre les consignes donc c'est
souvent parce que si c'est le cas aussi
sur le plan des les plus vulnérables des
gens qui ont des maladies chroniques et
les larges
je suis le lien que l'immunité avec
l'âge l'immunité diminue un peu donc il
faut penser à ces gens là les personnes
que vulnérable aussi madame brion les
personnes plus vulnérables
oui j'imagine point de vue physique ou
mental aussi puisque les génère déjà sur
comment est-ce que socialement va
pouvoir aider la résilience social de
notre population en traitent souvent du
trauma quand il est terminée là
maintenant on est face à de l'adversité
comment on peut on a un pouvoir sur la
capacité de résilience vraiment fait
cela par six nations ont été témoins des
difficultés de des couples prix sur ce
bateau d'un couple mineurs notamment qui
criaient à l'aide
je crois qu'on leur rende responsabilité
aussi au point de vue de ce qu'on va
donner comme information on
pour augmenter la capacité de tolérance
à l'incertitude et pour aussi donner
l'impression la population que j'ai un
sentiment d'auto efficacité qui
renforçait je me sens capable de
traverser cette épreuve tous ensemble ça
risque d'être difficile
mais cette épreuve doivent être
temporaires et je vais être capable la
traversée et pour ce faire
ça va être important d'avoir accès à de
l'information qui augmente le sentiment
d'auto efficacité donc de salaires
précise qu'ils nous donnent l'impression
qu'on peut avoir des stratégies
concrètes mais aussi des exemples
encourageants et donc pas seulement sur
des exceptions qui sont dramatisante
mais aussi sur des gens qui ont eu la
cabine 19 qui sont sorties qui ont guéri
par un dégât des eaux ces voix là et on
voit malheureusement beaucoup d'exemples
par exemple de ce qu'il ya de plus
affligeant dans la nature humaine parce
qu'on va parler aujourd'hui beaucoup
beaucoup de questions sur les gens qui
vont dans les épiceries mais tous les
gens qui ont décidé de sacrifier leurs
vacances qui sont dans le milieu de la
psychologie de la médecine des premiers
répondants et des militaires en
consultations qui vont un club pour la
population ça aussi ça va être très
important qu'on les voit qu'on voit
ainsi le plus bel aspect de l'être
humain et pas juste lille et beaucoup de
solidarité dans le milieu de la santé
des voisins risquent d'augmenter
justement de voir ces exemples-là
d'augmenter justement à l'est la
solidarité qui est très liée d'ailleurs
à la résidence pour viser quelque chose
je peux en fait non je pense
qu'effectivement le d'entourer n'y a ni
mal et pas que chez les humains la
solidarité plus importante que
l'agression alors dans un premier temps
quand on est agressé collectivement on a
peur mais dans un second temps on
s'entraide
c'est toujours comme ça quand ça se
passe mais des épidémies comme ça on
peut en sortir gagnant
on développe des méthodes qu'on ne
savait pas avant heureusement cette
épidémie ne se déroule dans un cercle
siècle où on a de la technologie collège
mais avant qui nous permet du
télétravail de la télémédecine des
choses qu'on ne savait pas qui va nous
forcer à changer nos pratiques
si on est intelligent dans la façon de
faire surtout on à la solidarité comme
le mentionne tous les panélistes on
risque d'en sortir plus grand accord que
si on avait pu éliminer seconde est
employé pour la fin des dix on peut
prendre des mesures de santé de
protection on n'a pas beaucoup de haute
technologie s'est tout récemment de la
distanciation mais il faut aussi se
rapprocher des gens qui en auront plus
le besoin mais le message est très clair
merci beaucoup de temps pour y acheter à
boire suivante et remercie beaucoup
madame brion d'être parlée merci de te
remercie beaucoup alors en termine en
raison de la situation exceptionnelle
que nous vivons ici redit est accessible
à tous dès maintenant même si vous
n'êtes pas abonné vous pourrez donc
suivre tous les développements de cette
crise à notre antenne d'ailleurs vous
soyez des nôtres ce dimanche pour une
émission spéciale découverte en direct
que j'aimerais en compagnie de mon
collègue animateurs de découverte
charles tisseyre avec nos journalistes
et spécialistes
nous ferons le point sur la situation du
cros de la vie ne coronavirus au canada
et sur la recherche de traitements et de
vaccins nos experts répondront aussi
encore une fois à vos questions sont
toujours très nombreuses rendez vous de
18h30 sur abbey et sur la première
chaîne très bonne fin de soirée si tous
pour ce soir le téléjournal sua
l'instant vers 700 fois
oh
[Musique]